[Musique]
je suis fleuriste à Londres je vois des
choses qui échappent à la plupart des
gens
un homme a déposé ceci aujourd'hui elle
vous a dit de qui ça provenait vous êtes
cordialement invité sur l'île la botte
pour une entrevue avec Monsieur Lewis
finly
Lorraine à votre service et personne n'a
rencontré fini aucun que nous l'adoliens
avec cet homme
excusez-moi où est Monsieur Findley tout
vous sera expliqué le moment venu
lors d'une
[Musique]
une ligne vous êtes pas une grosse
buveuse je préfère garder la tête froide
dans un environnement peu familier
ne se joindra pas à nous aujourd'hui
j'imagine que c'est le bureau de
Philippe
[Musique]
on devrait se réunir dans le salon
car il y a un meurtrier parmi nous
devons traiter tout le monde comme
suspect non attendez une seconde qui
peut faire une chose pareille c'est
peut-être un message vous n'appréciez
pas beaucoup notre autre on dirait
nous devons essayer de découvrir ce qui
nous relie pour comprendre qui a un vrai
mobile
vous devez vous salir les mains si vous
voulez connaître la vérité
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous faites là ils ont
toujours des secrets qui hésiteront pas
à protéger
d'autres combines ce drame toutefois ne
faisait pas partie du plan
servez-vous de ça trésor et si je ne
pouvais pas on va probablement tous
crever